Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Good news!
Another fluid paper is coming up today, and
this one is about simulating granular materials.
Most techniques that can simulate these grains
can be classified as either discrete or continuum
methods.
Discrete methods, as the name implies, simulate
all of these particles one by one.
As a result, the amount of detail we can get
in our simulations is unmatched, however,
you probably are immediately asking the question:
doesn’t simulating every single grain of
sand take forever?
Oh yes, yes it does.
Indeed, the price to be paid for all this
amazing detail comes in the form of a large
computation time.
To work around this limitation, continuum
methods were invented, which do the exact
opposite by simulating all of these particles
as one block where most of the individual
particles within the block behave in a similar
manner.
This makes the computation times a lot frendlier,
however, since we are not simulating these
grains individually, we lose out on a lot
of interesting effects, such as clogging,
bouncing and ballistic motions.
So, in short, a discrete method gives us a
proper simulation, but takes forever, while
the continuum methods are approximate in nature,
but execute quicker.
And now, from this exposition, the question
naturally arises: can we produce a hybrid
method that fuses together the advantages
of both of these methods?
This amazing paper proposes a technique to
perform that by subdividing the simulation
domain into an inside regime where the continuum
methods work well, and an outside regime where
we need to simulate every grain of sand individually
with a discrete method.
But that's not all, because the tricky part
comes in the form of the reconciliation zone,
where a partially discrete and partially continuum
simulation has to take place.
The way to properly simulate this transition
zone between these two regimes takes quite
a bit of research effort to get right, and
just think about the fact that we have to
track and change these domains over time,
because, of course, the inside and outside
of a block of particles changes rapidly over
time.
Throughout the video, you will see the continuum
zones denoted with red, and the discrete zones
with blue, which are typically on the outside
regions.
The ratio of these zones gives us an idea
of how much speedup we could get compared
to a purely discrete stimulation.
In most cases, it means that 88% fewer discrete
particles need to be simulated and this can
lead to a total speedup of 6 to 7 times over
that simulation.
Basically, at least 6 all nighter simulations
running now in one night?
I’m in.
Sign me up.
Also make sure to have a look at the paper
because the level of execution of this work
is just something else.
Check it out in the video description.
Beautiful work.
My goodness.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!